il déboutonne se protéger
il m'a attrapée par les cheveux
et où
il n'a pas tiré les cheveux et
puis la brochure sont mon visage de son
sexe vous voulez une fellation et là je
me suis débattue je me suis débattu
comme une folle comme jamais
j'avais mal aux cheveux
et quand il a vu que ça marchait pas
il s'est rhabillé et les parties
ses hommes
merci mais rien ne parlons pas d'être
avec nous directrice déléguée de public
c'est paris france dimanche s'il part il
rend ce dimanche exactement également
qui se faisait penser de cette enquête
sur que plusieurs
jeunes et j'ai trouvé ça plutôt pas mal
très courageux de la part tf1 en même
temps il n'avait pas trop le choix vous
n'avez pas le choix en fait la pression
ça fait beaucoup de bruit en interne
parce que tf1 ne prenait pas position
par rapport par rapport à toutes les
histoires qui sont sortis et tous les
témoignages qui concerne et des salons
commandes en urgence eux leurs portes là
ils ont dit lors des différents comités
sociaux d'entreprise que a7 a8 été fait
parce qu'en fait les représentants du
personnel leur ont reproché en fait
d'avoir donné la parole à patrick poivre
d'arvor temps quotidien et de ne jamais
ou de n'avoir jamais donné par le team
est
exprimé sur les témoignages des femmes
qui ont été victimes d'agressions
sexuelles alors justement la question
qu'on vous pose sur ce sur ce débris
voilà est-ce que vous trouvez voilà que
tf1 est allé a bien fait de le faire
voilà ce que parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui l'ont dit ils sont allés quand
même sont les comme c'était très à
charge qu'est-ce que j'en ai pensé que
j'ai pas trouvé que c'était à charge
adapte très fière alors on va voir juste
lors de la seule l'unique interview sur
le sujet en mars dernier ppda reprocher
le fait que personne n'ose témoigne à
visage découvert c'est chose faite
depuis l'article de libération est une
des sept femmes qui a témoigné dans le
journal le 8 novembre dernier audard les
48 ans et qu il n est à l'époque en
promo pour son livre à les contacter par
l'assistant de ppda est invité par le
journaliste assister à ces gîtes et à la
fin elle invite dans son bureau regarder
la halle et à visage découvert
reprise par derrière je n'ai rien vu
venir je me suis retrouvé avec sa langue
dans ma bouche et sa main dans mon
soutien gorge
sans même que je le vois venir j'étais
sidéré
et je les repousser et évidemment je me
suis levé et j'ai dit quelque chose
comme ça va pas je les rejeter tout de
suite et l'a très mal pris il était très
en colère et il est allé derrière son
bureau et rangeait ses feuilles façon
j'étais en misant manager du travail il
m'a raccompagné à la porte et il m'a dit
faites attention à vous et je lui ai dit
moi ça va par contre vous faites très
attention à vous oui j j'ai pas trouvé
que pour des journalistes aussi
talentueux que cette a8 c'était un bon
reportage pourquoi pas je trouve que
c'était plus qu'équilibré tellement
équilibrée que finalement il y avait
très peu de révélations on ne savait pas
qu'elle était l'angle des 400 ans de
vouloir minimiser les responsabilités
potentielles de ppda il en avait fait
beaucoup à décharge comment tu veux je
vous avoue que par rapport au travail
d'envoyé spécial j'ai trouvé que c'était
parler un peu
est-ce que vous avez des infos meriem ou
sur ppda bah oui en fait il est vrai
qu'il est très mal il est super mal il
paraît même qu'il est sous sanction
olitique il est au fond du trou ils vont
essayer quand même tf1 de l'avoir à
plusieurs reprises il a refusé de
s'exprimer il a vu le reportage comme et
depuis effectivement bas ils allaient
déjà pas hyper bien parce que lui ce
sont victimes de diffamation mais
l'après ce reportage il se sent vraiment
parce que c'est sur la chaîne tf1 le
champ même son ancien employeur et que
du coup pas forcément salles de classe
qui l'impressionnait être lâché par tous
et dont ce numéro de sept à huit tirs
soit il ya eu également le témoignage de
muriel reus ancienne directrice adjointe
d'une filiale de tf1 qui revenue sur une
scène qu'elle a vécue face à ppda
regarder
son assistant 18 musique patrick il est
21h je m'en vais elle quitte la pièce
elle ferme la porte à ce moment là il se
tourne vers moi ils me parlent pas
jacques souvenir qu'ils ont d'avoir
échangé des mots avec lui
il va fermer la porte à clé de secondes
après il est devant moi ils essaient
m'embrasser et en même temps il défait
son pantalon il se retrouve en caleçon
et je lui dis à ce moment là mais enfin
patrick qu'est-ce que tu en train de
faire et en plus tu connais mes liens
avec avec la direction générale de cette
maison
et y avait patrick le lay en particulier
avec qui j'ai changé de façon
extrêmement régulière et donc à ce
moment-là ça la salle a arrêté net
alors patrick lozès et le président de
tf1 les goûts moi j'étais pas pour que
tf1 le traite de cette manière là en
revanche j'ai un truc le reportage était
bien fait parce qu'ils sont bien
recontextualiser les peuples se sont
bien rencontrés que je lisais le fait
qu'entre les faits présumés et
aujourd'hui il ya eu un changement
d'époque une vraie libération d'apport
alain vrai questionnement sur les
l'emprise et le consentement donc ça
c'est très bien d'avoir appelé parce qu
on a vu plein d'articles tous les
témoignages étaient mélangés ont rappelé
pas excéder faits qui datent et même si
les accusations sont extrêmement graves
10 à 15 ou 20 ans donc je trouve qu'ils
ont bien fait leur boulot alors nouriel
reus justement choqués par la scène
qu'elle a vécu avec ppda tu décides
d'alerté patrick le lay donc le
président de tf1 à l'époque et voici la
réaction lendemain matin
j'appelle patrick les donc j'appelle la
présidence pour lui raconter ce qui
s'était passé la veille ça me semblait
important quand même de partager ça il
me dit ah non mais n'a quand même pas
osé aussi avec toi et donc cette
formulation a fait lui répond mais donc
si tu me dis ça ça veut dire que tu es
au courant de ce qui se passe et il me
répond oui on a entendu un certain
nombre de choses mais je m'en occupe une
journaliste de tf1
affirme avoir alerté dès la fin des
années 90 le directeur de l'information
de la chaîne robert namias d'une autre
affaire une agression sexuelle qu'elle
aurait subis
robert namias a répondu au site
mediapart le 23 novembre dernier je n'en
ai aucun souvenir ça ne veut pas dire
que ça n'a pas existé je n'ai jamais été
saisi d'aucune plainte ni moral ni
écrite concernant patrick poivre d'arvor
mais je ne met en doute la parole
d'aucune de ces femmes
oui du bernard montiel t'inquiéter en
plus à tf1 à l'époque les nouvelles de
ppr parce qu'il paraît qu'il est très
très noir je n'avais pas du tout alors
je dois dire que j'ai été profondément
choqué quand j'ai vu tout ça et entendu
tous ces plaignantes sincèrement c'est
pas l'homme que je connais voilà
maintenant je vais bon c'est pas pareil
avec vous sinon
nous a parlé comme ça hein et parler et
muret de reus et une amie celle qui sait
si c'est exprimer effectivement et c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque elle m'a dit mais tu
te rappelles page que je t'avais dit
qu'il a un comportement bizarre mais à
l'époque personne ne supposait que ça
allait aussi loin donc je redis j'ai été
profondément choqué d'entendre tout ça
mais il est vrai qu'il faut quand même
souligner l'hypocrisie de tf1 parce que
là maintenant ils ont une telle trouille
de ce monde de se retrouver sur les
raisons on voit beaucoup ça aussi oui
mais c'est normal parce que ils ont rien
dit jusqu'à présent il ya une espèce
d'omerta pendant des années je suis
désolé tout le monde dit tout le monde
savait tout le monde savait ils ont rien
fait donc tout le monde maintenant
essayer de se planquer donc en balance
un documentaire horrible parce que c'est
profondément choquant moi je suis très
choquée c'est beau mais surtout ce qu'il
y avait toujours un mode de
fonctionnement
c'est une entité ont été identiques les
invités à participer au jt et ensuite si
elle se retrouver soi dans la loge soit
dans son bureau sur la moquette être
forcé à faire un acte sexuel robert que
ça soit robert namias où vous ou francis
au patrick les pardons enfin ils ont été
avertis par les différentes femmes et
personnes à l'époque nagy même et rh à
l'époque était visiblement au courant
quand on se réfère à l' enquête de
mediapart pour preuve c'est que ils
avaient pour consigne aux rh de ne pas
prendre des assistants trop jolie pour
patrick poivre d'arvor de prendre plutôt
des garçons ou des femmes un peu enrobé
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est
assez hypocrite de la part de tf1 c'est
comme une justification en fait de faire
sept à huit mois on voit là se déployer
des faits anciens alors parmi ceux qui
acceptent de défendre ppda y en avait
dans le sujet n'avait eu hier mail son
ancienne assistante de la tf entre 99 et
2003 ont regardé ce qu'elle dit de ppr
home el hanout assisté ppda dans les
coulisses du jt
et la compagnie en plateau entre 1999 et
2003 je n'ai jamais vu manquer de
respect à une femme je ne lui ai jamais
connu un geste déplacé ni un mot déplacé
ce n'est pas du tout l'homme que je
connais mon pays contre avait une
rédaction qui bossent serait sous la
sous la coupe d'un pervers polymorphe
ça ça se serait su bien au delà il
personne et tout le monde se serait
barre et aucune femme ne serait resté
bas à huy mathieu moi ce qui m'agace un
peu pardon défend tf1 mais je suis sûr
non je peux vous savez droite défend de
tf1 m'agace un peu c'est le côté d'abord
tout le monde savait tout le monde
savait banon par tout le monde savait
pas si tout le monde savait si tout le
monde savait ça veut dire que donc toute
la rédaction du jt le savez sans doute
la red hat ou toute l'information le jde
le savez tous les patrons le savez que
c'est pas seulement les grands patrons
c'est que tous ceux qui bossaient à la
jtf à tous les journalistes donc tout le
monde à tf1 le savez puisque tout le
monde le savait tout le monde sous le
couvert à la vie tout le monde l'a
couverte c'est ce qu'on est en train de
l'aurait couvert
parce que dans le temps il n'y avait pas
la parole qui a été libéré et
aujourd'hui quand on parle de
prescription bon là c'est pas encore ben
forcément le cas mais je trouve ça
immonde quand il ya des faits qui se
sont passés si ça fait 5 ans 10 ans ou
même quarante ans ça reste des faits
immonde et et la mauvaise foi moi je la
retrouve dans la personne tout à l'heure
qui a parlé et qui disait
je n'ai plus se souvenir la salle de la
mairie ça n'a pas existé en fait c'est
bon c'est pas c'est du lard ou
d'approché alors ils sont allés très
loin dans les airs dans cet avis puisque
ils sont 89 un premier témoignage contre
ppda qui étaient sortis dans la presse
non mais non minutes journal d'extrême
droite une jeune fille mineure à
l'époque témoigne contre la star du 20
heures de tf1 l'article titre à l'époque
un satyre à tf1 une star abuse d'une
lycéenne regarder dans mes souvenirs et
commence par l'embrasser
ça j'ai une image très net sur le canapé
ou en partie sur moi en tout cas je me
retrouve sans le bas et maintenant
allongée sur la moquette et là il se met
devant moi
lui
il est comme moi c'est à dire qu'il a
enlevé le bas
et en érection
est là sans ce en quoi que ce soit
d'autre en fait sont sensualité sans
quoi que ce soit il me pénètre moi j'ai
eu l'impression de m'être à avelin
laisser faire en fait et ça ça a été
fait c'est quelque chose dont j'ai tout
sucre tout de suite pris conscience
guillaume non ils y sont allés femmes
s'ils font un effort sur les témoignages
c'est vrai mais pas sur le rôle de tf1
évidemment que sur tf1 ils vont pas se
tirer une balle dans le pays vont pas
dire une ba nous vous révélons
aujourd'hui que la chaîne était au
courant donc moi je comprends les gens
qui ont parlé d' hypocrisie d'une parce
qu'ils ont pu évidemment balayé un peu
toutes les accusations qui est contre
tf1 dans la presse et deux parce qu'il
ya des personnes aussi qu'andy sur les
réseaux ils se sont mis à la place de
pépé d'alison dit ma propre chaîne me
trahis et me là il est présumé innocent
donc moi j'ai trouvé ça dégueulasse
atari a fallu ramer lâcher alors non
mais à l'époque allez vous êtes tous
candidats à l'époque quand on parlait
c'est ce que 10 minutes et est vrai
quand on parlait les gens disaient vous
salissez tout vous mentez et à l'époque
c'est lé pa cours ont donné la parole
raison ou puissants et la fille qui se
plaignait repartait en ayant la
sensation d'être une sale menteuse tout
le monde la maîtrise de ma mère à
l'époque maintenant mais j'espère que ça
va là pour être
dans mes séries en battant est important
la scala explications mathieu labadie
je fais partie des gens à qui on disait
mais vous êtes d'où vous êtes des
menteuses vous salissez tout vous dans
les médias parce qu'il est puissant et
lui disait abandonné le lait un jour la
farine aux élections que cette règle
n'est président de tf1 et et paye
patrick a répondu mais elles sont toutes
jalouses et cdti de la jalousie et on
les croyait je suis désolé on les
croyait
mais moi je suis pas d'accord avec
gilles honnête intellectuellement parce
que je trouve que c'est quand même
certes opportuniste de la part de la f1
mais c'est quand même édifiant bah oui
parce qu'on a lu les témoignages de ces
femmes dans libération mais de les voir
face comme un peu comme avec culot
pascal expliqué tout le protocole comme
ça les fait revenir à 21h descend de son
pantalon et ça pour ça serait le même
mode opératoire c'est très choquant ils
ont quand même trouvé une chic avait 16
ans à l'époque une victime présumée donc
c'est quand même aussi très très
édifiant alors évidemment c'est dans
minute alors pas de bol parce que c'est
pas la bien pensante à main chanel avait
elle l'avait fait son témoignage ses
parents voilà pour que ses parents ses
parents le dit viser une
icône a salué douala
un cigare moi j'ai trouvé ça quand même
très réussi effectivement tf1 on va à
tâtons sur tf1 mais il ya quand même
nonce paolini qui est un petit peu je
parle il ya robert place et amélie qui
est un garçon
né mon engagement ailleurs on croit à la
parole des femmes bah oui ne suis pas au
courant ont privé le surnommait je vous
dise non c'était beaucoup
alors c'est en fait un homme et où le
bébé mais pourquoi ils étaient pas il
n'était pas il n'était pas là il est et
il n'était pas du tout l'été cigale
bruit le donc rien à voir en tout cas il
est pendu dans le vivant dans le
documentaire ils reprennent les propos
de mediapart il ya personne qui vient de
visu dire les choses quand on me disait
comme disait car chazal on n'a jamais
parlé de viols à tf1 n'ont jamais parlé
de lourde au et de gros séducteur voilà
je suis désolé on n'a jamais parlé de
viol
[Musique]
isabelle dit on et ça
c'est pas mal warnock un quart des vols
d'essai pas draguer saison pourquoi
mettre la main dans le décolleté et
c'est sa drogue
je dis simplement qu'on dit que cole à
l'époque à tf1 en discuter un grand
éditeur et un gros lourdaud maintenant
le reste non c'est tout ce qu'on a vu et
édifiant et très choquant et vous en
pensez quoi lourdaud en fait je ne sais
pas mais c'est ce qu'on disait à tf1 en
tout cas
je vais présenter le passage à l'an 2000
et donc je vais à la rédaction et je
vais rencontrer claire chazal et patrick
pas pour effet brassage à l'an 2000 oui
avec aisance et isabelle a fait le
passage de l'ombre
auprès d'eux il y aurait deux duos
y'avait claire chazal et patrick poivre
d'arvor et moi et jean-claude maenner
claude et jean claude mercier moi pardon
et donc on fait une énorme conférence de
rédaction ce que c'est un énorme barnum
au sortir de cette conférence de
rédaction son assistante m'appelle en me
disant patrick aimerait mieux vous
connaître aimerait mieux vous rencontrer
et savoir qui vous êtes on va déjeuner à
l'époque si je vous dis pas de bêtises
chez lui ce parce que c'est là où il
mena où il invite allait bien tout ça
mais qui sont je le dis a évidemment
tout le monde parce que c'est la méga
star et moi je suis très fier sur jeune
journaliste je fais un incroyable quand
on allait déjeuner castaldi à l'époque
et moi personne ne m'a dit attention tu
risques statut risque
d'être violées ou de subir quelque chose
de très grave on m'a dit 'il va te
draguer
jaradi plus donc le côté vous a été
hyper dragueur très charmant très
charmeur mais à aucun moment je suis
senti en danger au point de me dire je
prends mon sac et je m'en vais je vous
disais je reconnais pas l'homme à ceux
de ce reportage c'est très choquant je
suis très choqué d'avoir vu tout ça et
les plaignantes elles ont raison
heureusement que la parole se libère
enfin c'est extrêmement choquant j'avoue
que j'étais très choquée
je les comprends très bien je mets en
revanche moi j'ai deux cas précis dans
mon entourage professionnel où les
jeunes femmes étaient allés le soir chez
lui et ça ça a été difficile pour elle
voilà et l on peut encore parler elle
n'allait pas elle ne parlait pas très
passant par les là dans libération donc
non par ben non parce qu'il y en a une
je sais qu'elle n'a pas parlé ce moment
là elle ne parlera jamais d'accord est
en colère y en a d'autres le témoignage
en ouvre l'enquète sur sept à huit c'est
un nouveau témoignage on l'avait entendu
nulle part en le suivant mais myriam
alors aujourd'hui c'est quoi la suite ce
qu'on n'arrête pas d'entendre parler il
c'est quoi la suite mais en fait la
suite c'est beaucoup d'effets sont quand
même prescrit donc qui reste leur flamme
de florence porcel on a parlé la
dernière fois qu'ils qui akelarre porté
plainte et qui sépare et qui s'est mise
au pas partie civile qui s'est
constituée partie civile et du coup il
ya un juge d'instruction qui a été qui
va donc être
voilà comment tirer ce coup de massue
que je perds je perds mes mots on a
compris voilà et du coup bas il va pas
il va il va à nouveau entendre tous les
témoignages et voilà et il risque et
ppda aujourd'hui tu sors pas de chez lui
c'est votre iphone il continue de courir
tous les matins donc ça c'est ça c'est
sûr mais effectivement il va hyper mal
et ce qui se dit dans le milieu c'est
qu'effectivement il prend certains
médicaments pour pour se sentir après
les infos vu il ya deux nouvelles
plaintes qui ont été déposées et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ces deux
familles ont déposé plainte en sachant
que c'est des prescrits pour faire leur
devoir de citoyenne dit l'avocat
pourquoi elle porte plainte c'est parce
qu'elle espère que d'autres vont
témoigner et le juge d'instruction va ré
entendre tout le monde pour
éventuellement trouver des faits non
prescrits et laissèrent leur jeu là
c'est sympa les enjeux
le deuxième violent de florence porcel
qui met par ailleurs justement tous ces
témoignages la même prescrit vont être
ajoutés au dossier et donc après c'est à
l'appréciation du juge d'instruction de
se dire est ce que tout ça fait des
faisceaux concordants et dans un cadre
de parole contre parole aider la
plaignante